Let's get to handling our
second integration point,
between the application and the user.
In particular, we allow for
free form text entry of the location.
That means there are multiple ways
the user can get something wrong.
The user can input text that doesn't
actually resolve to a location or
the user can input text that resolves
to a different location than they
are expecting.
We're going to look at
handling the first problem,
the user inputting text that
doesn't resolve to a location.
The second problem is a bit trickier.
Many users use ZIP codes to set
their location, because we use that,
by default, in our application.
One of the fascinating parts about the
world's postal system is the fact that
postal codes tend to be unique within
each country, rather than truly unique.
As a result, sometimes a postal
code in which was intended for
location in the United States will
return information for a location
outside the United States, even if
the postal code is properly written.
In addition,
there are often cities around the world
that share the same name.
Unless the user types in the entire
name, including state, province, and
country, we may get this wrong as well.
Note that we currently have
a function that maps the location.
So, a determined user can find out where
their weather search is geolocated.